nous organisons aujourd'hui ici dans les
locaux d'edf lab à saclay le premier
colloque scientifique sur la transition
énergétique sur le plateau de saclay
donc c'est organisé conjointement par
l'université paris saclay et par edf il
ya ce qu'on appelle un écosystème sur
l'énergie qui est vraiment vivant sur le
plateau de saclay on part de la
recherche la plus fondamentale à la
recherche appliquée et aux écosystèmes
industriels donc on a décidé de faire un
premier colloque scientifique pour
montrer qu'il y avait de grandes actions
de recherche qui a été menée sur le
plateau de saclay et que ces actions de
recherche elles n'étaient pas menées
indépendamment par chacun des organismes
et que grâce à l'université paris saclay
à cette commune nous avons mis ensemble
les chercheurs nous avons créé des
départements de recherche
ces prêts département de recherche sont
plutôt disciplinaire mais ils ont chacun
d'énergie au coeur de leurs
préoccupations
l'énergie est un enjeu sociétal qui est
un enjeu en particulièrement prégnant en
ce moment puisque nous sommes un an
après la signature de l'accord 21
et puis un petit peu plus d'un an après
la signature de la loi on appelle la loi
l lt au cv donc la loi dans la
transition énergétique pour une
croissance verte
donc l'objectif de ces deux jours c'est
vraiment de montrer qu est-ce que
l'université paris saclay l'ensemble de
ces chercheurs mais aussi l'ensemble de
ses collaborations avec le site de tissu
industriel peut apporter à cette
thématique de la transition énergétique
en parallèle à ce colloque nous avons
organisé un forum étudiant qui permet
aux étudiants qui font leurs études sur
le plateau de saclay de venir rencontrer
leurs futurs employeurs c'est à dire
soit des industries soit des organismes
de recherche
et puis nous donnons aussi une grande
part aux étudiantes au sein même du
colloque puisque nous avons organisé une
session posters et nous sommes ici au
milieu d'une salle où vous voyez exposer
les post elle est ma à l'issue de ces
deux journées nous attribuerons cinq
prix au meilleur poster qui auront été
réalisés mais c'est vraiment l'occasion
aux doctorants de venir présenter leurs
travaux de recherche aux 300 personnes
qui sont venues ici au colloque pour la
transition énergétique sur le plateau de
saclay
m